I mean obviously the watchwords of the
Irish presidency where stability growth
and jobs and we focused a lot of our
energies on matters rated banking Union
and financial stability and and you know
we as you know we were able to complete
negotiations with department on crd for
and on the SSM and those are two of the
examples of offerings drew left for us
by the Cyprus presidency for our part
last Wednesday as you know we managed to
conclude the negotiations on banking
resolution recovery and resolution but
it'll now fall to the theory Nia Lewis
lesions in the council on BRR and
roulette forward to the terranea to
carry forward the trial arms with the
Parliament another important financial
services file we completed was method
and and there that too will be for
Lithuania to bring forward with with the
Parliament of course as you know we we
also emphasized very heavily work on the
mff and all the total goes with it and
at the eleventh hour we reached a deal
with the Parliament which is voting this
week at kiratpur on Friday afternoon we
formally endorsed the the texts and pass
these on to the Parliament we managed to
complete negotiations also in terms DMF
on horizon 2020 and on Erasmus for all
and which were very very important
reason kazmi residence plus I beg your
pardon and I would cause me that's not
my side Corp one and you know then of
course we we placed a lot of emphasis is
also on the the eu-us trade partnership
and we got a deal on the t tip mandate
on the fourteenth of June down in
Luxembourg you here so people Toki over
at times about running a president for
the first time well Ireland ran what was
a very successful first presidency in
1975 which was two years after we joined
the European Union lithuania has at nine
years to prepare for this and so I have
no doubt that it'll be a great success